okay here we are on CNN and this is our
panel he's co-hosted the fifth column
podcast Michael Moynihan he's co-host of
the YouTube show and podcast
trigonometer and the author of an
immigrant's love letter of the West
Constantine Kissin all right thank you
gentlemen
Elon is uh had to go and save the world
and I think he will okay here are the
questions will Russia's bombing of
Ukraine's Capital City prompt a oh yeah
I saw that on the news today horrible
saw it on CNN
yeah prompt a counter-offensive
supported by Western allies
um no the counter offensive is coming
anyway it's nothing to do with the
bombing uh the ukrainians have been
planning this for a long time uh they've
been waiting for what they call rasputes
in that part of the world which is mud
season to be over and also training up
uh their forces with Western weapons
tanks Etc so the count offensive is
coming the actual these bombings of of
the civilians they're not all they're
doing is strengthening the result of the
ukrainians more than anything else other
than of course killing and maiming
innocent people so uh the counter
offensive is coming but it's not because
of that how does this War end
well I've said from day one that I think
the likely outcome is that Ukraine will
make some territorial concessions uh
which will be Crimea and parts of the
donbass and likely that will be in
exchange for what Ukraine actually needs
which is long-term security and in my
opinion there's no other way of
providing it other than either NATO
membership or U.N peacekeepers On the
Border but I don't think that's going to
happen so most likely Ukraine has a
successful counter offensive pushes
pushes Russia as far away as it can and
then makes a settlement that means that
what happened in 2014 remember we talked
about it earlier when Crimea and parts
of the donbass were first taken that can
never happen again because Ukraine is
now part of NATO and is therefore Under
the Umbrella of that organization but
you you see Putin ever making
concessions I mean we talk a lot in this
country about how long Biden's going to
last I keep reading that he's sick Putin
is that just a rumor do you have
relatives in Russia I have relatives in
both countries but nobody really knows I
mean I don't know if you know this they
take his poo in a bag and it's kept
separate from it no one can analyze it
so he's the information isn't getting
out let's put it that way
how do you know that so you're saying
they take the Putin pool and put it they
keep it separate when he goes abroad
they they keep hold of it because
well how could everybody get it it goes
down the toilet maybe he maybe he shits
in a bag maybe that's what we've
discovered right now with CNN you can't
say bad words here first it's not live
there is it oh no but it's not edited
either I forgot okay this is new the CNN
thing I don't know
um but on on the Putin thing is the
sickness we saw in those in those uh
files that were leaked by that like 11
year old kid in the National Guard of
Massachusetts was the the intelligence
uh analysts say that he has cancer and
his leg shakes all the time and as far
as concessions I mean the only way that
most ukrainians see this and you know
from the polling of ukrainians they
don't want to get up any territory of
course in the way that uh this ends is
Russia loses and he does pull out you
see that what happened in in Kiev I mean
they tried at the very beginning of this
war to encircle Kiev and cut off the
head of the snake what they thought and
they were they were routed by an army
that at that point didn't even have all
the Western weapons that they have now
and these tank Columns of Tanks coming
in and being picked off but plainly
backed out but plainly he could bomb
okay much more than he has he that's
what we were seeing on the news today
well you know the apartment build it's
just pointless well not pointless if
you're a terrorist because not
militarily pointless yeah militarily
pointless except for the long range goal
of winning the war and making people
just say uncle and that seems to be
winter bombing I mean the entire point I
mean look I you know criticize it if you
will I mean what we did in Germany in
1943 44 and 45 was to bomb and say we
were going to break publicly said this
bummer Harris said we're going to break
their spirit and that's right something
that ended here now in 1945 the Russians
are doing this today but that isn't that
isn't what's happening on the ground I
remember on the first day of the war I
called up one of my friends in Kiev and
I said to him listen I've talked to some
people you need to get out and he said
to me you still remember this
conversation he said this is different
to 2014. we're not this is our country
we're not leaving
and what is happening in Ukraine now
with these bombings it's only
strengthening their resolve
[Applause]
well they're brave people they are
incredible all right what does the panel
think of a recent poll that puts
Democratic presidential Challenger RFK
Jr yes if you hadn't gotten the news
Robert Kennedy Jr the son of Robert
Kennedy yeah our former Attorney General
uh at 19 I saw that today too can he
hope to I must say I'm surprised that
right off the bat he's polling at 19
Kennedy name helps yeah 19 how many
names but another another poeterman 17
so they seem to be in line in that you
know Marianne Williamson is at nine
percent so you have a chunk of people
and when you we talked about this in the
main shows 70 of them of Americans don't
want Joe Biden to run again 50 of
Democrats there are people looking for
Alternatives and I really wish it wasn't
Robert Kennedy but the DNC right now is
you know lining up the troops and going
to prevent him from doing any damage
they're not going to have debates
there's going to be no primary debates
he's just going to be pushed aside if
he's running as a Democrat if he decides
to then run as a third party candidate
you have a our situation and why don't
you like them why don't who I mean you
said you wish it wasn't him why yeah I
wish it wasn't him for a variety of
reasons I mean you know Kennedy said
something in 2013 that uh you know
frequent guests in the show Matt Welsh
just just tweeted about was you know he
thinks that you know climate deniers
should be put in jail there should be
regulations against people denying
climate change his past is checkered
with this stuff it's not just the VAC
stuff I don't get into those issues I
don't know a ton about it that's not my
area of expertise at all you know he
said too many nice things about Hugo
Chavez in Venezuela as his brother Joe
has to it's just a very weird and he's
becoming more conspiratorial to the sort
of they are censoring me all the time I
just don't you're a Kennedy your last
book sold two million copies no
uncensoring it so I don't like that kind
of instinct it's not my it's not my kind
of right but but they won't treat what
he is saying about covid no of course
not no with but they should yes like
many people have written about but
including the US government you've got a
lot wrong he might be getting stuff
wrong sure but he's not a nut yeah I
mean he's not a nut and he's not a nut
about covet either or vaccines well the
thing about this is that you know it's
hard to tell these days it's hard to
tell because you could get kicked off of
Facebook of YouTube of all this stuff
we're saying that this came from a lab
in Wuhan not from a wet Market in Wuhan
but the lab right that did bad viruses
that was down the street that people got
people like lots of people not just like
a one errant person that was kicked off
once no this was very very common that
was all these things you couldn't say
then which are now conventional and what
we know about medicine is always
changing on a day-to-day basis I mean
just last year they got metabolism wrong
they came out with this big report that
said we'd always thought it was slowed
down in age and it doesn't slow in age
that's kind of a basic part of our
health and that and you can read stories
like that almost year to year they've
also got depression wrong oh it wasn't
the serotonin okay I'm not saying it's
corrupt although there is quite a bit of
that too
somehow when it's the Sackler family
with the opioids it's like go see
corporations and pharmaceutical
companies but when it's covered oh no
they must have everything on the up and
up okay but say it's not mostly that
they were trying and they did a great
thing they came up with a vaccine which
many people most people needed and saved
millions of lives that's true too Robert
Kennedy may not agree with that but your
point is entirely correct bill which is
I think a lot of people have forgotten
how we got to be successful in the west
and part of that is freedom of speech
and freedom of research right especially
inside in science especially in medicine
we need people
to be able to talk about the facts and
when you have some kid who works for
Twitter in the Philippines censoring a
Nobel prize-winning scientist in his
speaking about his era of expertise I
think we've lost the plot right one
final point on this is the number of
people who are wearing t-shirts that
said I believe in science science became
this thing that was the conventional
wisdom coming from the government from
the CDC I believe in that that's what
they're talking about you cannot believe
in science science is a process right
it's always changing right and people
thought I could believe in science they
thought it never moved and they were
surprised and that's the thing the left
the far paranoid coveted left talks
about science like its religion the
science yeah while they're doing things
like wearing masks alone outside yes the
science
foreign
what does the panel think of Steven
Spielberg saying he regretted replacing
guns with Wakita oh yes in the
walkie-talkies in E.T yeah he he
re-edited to E.T and now he's regretting
that and I'm so glad he is he's saying
movies were made of a certain time
they're all going to look weird in the
future in some way leave them as they
are I think it's terrific
hey man
yeah the really scary thing is that
classic books and I think this is what
precipitated his comment on this was
Roald Dahl who was a psycho in an
anti-semite but a good uh good
children's book author and he has some
pretty negative portrayals of people
he's not the Jews he doesn't talk about
the kids book and they changed the most
banal thing fat you literally can't say
fast yeah I don't know what did they
change it to it was like nicely shapely
I don't know it wasn't a body positive
that's what they probably changed
this kind of thing is insane but they're
actually changing books and that is
literally orwellian not the abuse of the
word we got to make way for commercials
we're here on CNN thank you again we'll
see you next week
foreign